Mental Health Services for adolescents
should always be top priority Desert
Wind Hospital the sponsors of this
segment ensure that here in southern
Nevada and also Nationwide
[Music]
hi my name is Adina Archibald boujet I'm
the director of Clinical Services here
at Desert Winds Hospital Desert Winds is
a freestanding psychiatric facility that
caters to adolescents ages 12 to 17. so
post covet what we've seen is a
significant increase in depression
amongst adolescents having difficulty
returning to a regular school setting
haven't been home for such a long period
of time with the stressors of
potentially their family having lost
their jobs and maybe not being able to
provide them the same level of care that
they were having before when you arrive
at Desert Winds whether it be from
another facility or as a walk-in patient
who is in crisis you will be met with an
admissions counselor who will provide
you with an assessment to determine
what's the best level of care if it is
that you're in crisis severe enough to
require inpatient hospitalization they
will walk you through the steps of
getting admitted into the hospital here
Desert Winds we take an integrated
approach with to care we include the
families as well was a psychiatrist a
doctors teachers therapists to ensure
that we're providing the optimal care
for their child quite frequently
families are concerned with payment
options and how to get access to their
services for their child we do accept
several different Insurance coverages
such as Nevada Medicaid Tricare
as well as commercial insurances we also
use Care Credit as a payment option for
the families if they need it accessing
residential treatment is quite difficult
for adolescents so we want to ensure
that we also offer this to out-of-state
patients so to accommodate that we offer
things such as modified timing for phone
calls when they live on the east coast
first per se or Airport pickup and
specialized therapeutic classes for the
families when they come to visit we can
accommodate Patients Out Of State on our
acute level of care as well as our prts
our prtf is a little bit different in
that it is a longer term stay our
average length of staying acute is five
to seven days while on prtf is
approximately 90 based on the patient's
needs on our prtf we do provide
recreational therapy process groups
cycle education groups 24-hour nursing
care as well as 24-hour observations by
mental health techs we do have a fully
licensed school so the patients can
receive credits while they are here so
they are not pushed behind in their
academic Journey when they return home
and if you are part of our acute care
much like prtf you will receive an
evaluation from a psychiatrist and be
provided oversight by the psychiatrists
daily you will receive a therapist
process group psycho education groups a
smaller version of educational materials
so that you can stay current in your
education and you will also receive
24-hour nursing care as well as 24-hour
observation prtf candidates will be
candidates who are no longer in crisis
and need longer-term care so that they
can reintegrate slowly into to the
community acute care is Crisis driven
and that they become they are currently
a danger to themselves or others or
demonstrate an inability to care for
themselves here at Desert Winds our goal
is to provide the best care possible to
youngsters who are struggling I myself
have been a social worker for over 20
years and I am proud of the program that
we built here our goal is to make sure
that the patients can go back safely to
their homes go back to school and be
safe and be able to cope in this world
because things are pretty difficult now
thank you to Desert Winds hospital for
sponsoring that segment for more call
702-202-2711 or visit
desertwindshospital.com we'll be right
back